[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
going to be talking about
being caught in the gaze and some of the
philosophical psychological
film theory all sorts of other
theory things about what it means to
have somebody else looking at you and
there's a lot of implications to this
it was about
well it was right after we recorded our
last session that dan and i were kicking
around ideas and i remember you said
i want to talk about jean-paul sartre
and the gays and i was like well that's
that's kind of out of left field but
that sounds pretty cool to talk about
because as as it turns out is we're
gonna talk you know i'll i'll relate to
you sart used to be my favorite
philosopher a long time ago and i spent
a lot of time
thinking through this stuff so i was
actually very happy to hear you say that
you wanted to
talk about that and i'm still left
wondering a little bit well why what
what brought that up was there something
on your mind
at that point in time that made you
steer in that existentialist direction
well you know we we do this podcast
slash youtube video and
radio show and we look at each other and
so there's always
you know once we're on camera we can see
ourselves
um there's a gaze effect upon ourselves
as well as you know we're putting
ourselves out there
but also i i see it
in like interactions and day-to-day i
think one of the main things that i see
especially from certain pieces we'll get
into it like really significantly but is
the male gaze
and the um
the reduction
of of people especially females to kind
of this you know uh phacticity and this
um
you know desire
motive uh as this you know kind of
physical or sexual object and not as
a
individual themselves
and how we turn these uh individuals
into these objects or these means to our
own kind of like desired ends and not
having them uh at all be their own
subjects to not have them
uh
be ends in in themselves
you know it's interesting when you think
about it so
jean-paul start talks about the gays
right uh his lifelong
partner from
um from college onward uh simonda
bouvoir
is a major existentialist figure who
completed some of the work that sartre
himself didn't do and she she writes
about feminism extensively in the second
sex not using the the term the gays but
unpacking it a bit
and you think about those two as
lovers
i mean
sarge is kind of harder to think about
because he was not a good looker you
know i mean he must have had one hell of
a personality and in some ways
when you compare him to to anybody else
like you know albert camus or uh people
like that on the scene um but you know
these these people were together
for decades
and
you know when you think about the things
that they say about the gays and about
sexuality and about relationships
it makes you wonder
what their own relationship must have
been like living out these realities
that they're they're analyzing
you know that at least it makes me think
about that a good bit
have you have you ever
has that ever been on your mind i mean
now it's stuck in your head right yeah
absolutely um
to a certain extent
i i definitely have not thought a bit
about it as much as you have uh but
yeah the
the both the the second sex on as as the
individual work
um
as well as just the extent of
existentialism you know
leads these questions of how
uh one interacts uh not only with
oneself and society but like with the
people that they are closest to yeah
that's that's very important um
it's not something
merely abstract that you do in the
classroom you're right
the people that you are closest to
whether they're your friends and family
or your neighbors
or and for many of us are co-workers
that's where the real test of practical
philosophy comes out isn't it
right
are you going to actually
act in accordance with the things that
you've come to
accept as the best way of moving forward
and interacting with those other people
yeah so i want to say a little bit about
sartre and about this uh this book being
and nothingness because
it's you know it's a big thick tome and
that's where we find this really
interesting discussion of the the gays
or the look in french the regard
that that comes out of it can be
translated either way and it's it's a
very dense tome right sart has a great
facility for developing examples some of
which we're going to talk about like you
know the gays coming from the farmhouse
on the hill where a sniper might be
waiting for you to walk out into the
field very concrete right very easy to
to relate to and wrap your head around
or the famous example which which we
won't analyze here but the waiter who is
being too much of a waiter which you can
see today in coffee shops and cafes and
you know restaurants here in the
milwaukee area
because there's still people playing
that that game but his his analyses are
on the one hand very
deep and technical and metaphysical and
on the other hand they're focused on
the things that we have in everyday life
that we can relate to and that's i think
that's part of what makes this
this book still i mean it's over half a
century old um actually it's more than
it's it's i think 70 set over 70 years
old now right isn't it um maybe and
actually 80 perhaps right is it 41 i
think so
but it's still fresh i mean some of the
terminology like you know what you do in
a cafe has changed a little bit um
he talks about you know a phonograph
needle or something like that yeah we
know what that is but maybe some of our
younger listeners unless they're audio
files
you know what uh uh finals coming back
it's it's been the the most selling it
has like at least oh really that's oh
yeah that's kind of cool to to know
um in any case this book for me when i
was
a young man
was i won't say my bible um but i i
treated it with that with a similar kind
of reverence that that some people do
and i was for a while trying to live as
an existentialist than a sartre and
existentialist i was captivated
by this i can't claim that i actually
understood everything that he said
at that point in my my career and
development but i thought there was a
lot to this and and i you know i
connected it together with simone de
bevoir and i filled in some parts with
some some other existentialist thinkers
as well
and this these analyses really kept i
remember be where i sat in the library
reading these and and you know saying
wow this is amazing stuff
um back when i was 20 21 22 years old
yeah it's when you first are
exposed to these ideals it really
is a
major deviation from how
most of us are presented the world and
once you are presented in this way that
seems both alien but also
exceedingly salient yeah
yeah it is that that whole like oh
this is this moment of like like
little explosions of enlightenment as
you go through this is like oh that's
such a different way to look at that but
it also makes so much sense
yeah that's i mean that's actually a
great topic
um
that applies to
well it applies to practical philosophy
it also applies to reading great
literature
sometimes history can provoke that sort
of thing anthropological studies when
you find out how somebody else
lives and how their language is
differently oriented
there's this this word that's um that
was coined
by i think structural linguistics uh
people
quite a while back called
defamiliarization
and and it's it's used to describe
exactly that process you're sitting
there it could be reading a book it
could be like listening to somebody
explain something it could be
um
having a culinary experience that is
kind of mind-blowing and
suddenly a whole world opens up and it's
an unfamiliar world which could be scary
could be exciting could be all sorts of
things but it's you know to use that old
expression you're definitely not in
kansas anymore
right and
to some people these are
exciting experiences and so some people
these are really
kind of frightening experiences
part of it is how
willing you are to
be open to those new experiences and new
ways of looking at someone and you can
either
um
you know kind of regress and go well i
don't like you know a caribbean food or
whatever food that you've tried because
like it's it's weird and it's uh
unfamiliar where you can you can take
that jump that leap
um into
that new experience and
uh tar start to experience that as a new
whole new world that you can
like live in and yeah and eventually it
does become a world that you're familiar
with
and it can also become boring and
mundane right you've been there done
that too much you know um but
this is how we expand our lives and
so this is a great lead-in to talking
about the look because the look has to
do with the other and
part of what happens let's take the
culinary you know example um you go to a
restaurant with one of your friends
and let's say it's a diner actually will
make it really
really american really straightforward
you always order the same thing like for
me my go-to and diners
is a patty melt with fries and then a
bowl of chili that i can dip the fries
into and i i like that you know it's
it's very homey it's got all the
different things that i am kind of into
but i'll also try other stuff you know
if i see something cool that's a special
oh that that that sounds kind of nice um
but let's say i'm the kind of person
who's really stuck with my
my my regular thing my what
what do we call that your usual right
yeah uh so you and i are at the diner
and you're like hey um have you tried
this thing you know you tried eggs with
kimchi well that's a good one yeah yeah
now
that's i you know i've had that but i've
had it pretty late in my life
it's not something that i
stumbled my way into right where did you
where did you have it
what was the experience for you i don't
know if i've actually had directly eggs
with kimchi but i've had like um oh
there used to be a a little restaurant
on the east side here in milwaukee that
had a kimchi bowl as a part of their
like diner breakfast oh
yeah
yeah interesting
so you you say hey why don't you try
this i like it and i
you know i could say no to it i'm gonna
stick with what i know that i like and
then i never i never have that
experience that possible experience and
when i do have it i might feel that it
really is weird and foreign
to me because i'm who would associate
those those two things together eggs
that's fine with bacon or
uh what else what are other vegetable
things hash browns exactly yeah yeah
not kimchi you know
um what is kimchi kimchi is only for
korean food right all right
um
but you know if i if i do lend myself to
it then i can have this unfolding of
experience and i can have it because you
have said this is a possibility you've
you've opened up my world a little bit
it's not just me like
looking at stuff on my phone which which
is also others you know i mean the words
and pictures didn't just get there by at
least at this point by some ai putting
them there
right right
maybe there's another yeah maybe there's
another conversation i have about that
down the line um
but so so the other plays a really
central role
and
you know when when i try that eggs with
kimchi
i can like go off by myself and not be
in front of you while i'm doing it so
that my facial expression doesn't betray
uh my unfamiliarity
or my joy or my anguish or anything like
that
if i am doing it in front of you you're
seeing me eating right and tasting and
doing this very human activity
and i'm in a certain way
subject to you
right you you could say what's wrong
with you what's what's that look on your
face about
yeah i'm gonna take this in a slightly
different way because when i was younger
i
um you know we made some a couple of
like you know stupid stupid student
films of which one was like a
interesting
of uh macbeth and monty python's holy
grail oh wow
and so i i i showed this to my father
and i
i edited the film i've seen it a number
of times i don't need to watch it
anymore and i sat there and just watched
him
and i i noticed that he was watching me
watching him
and being aware
of me watching him and like
like what are you gonna do i was like
your child is sitting here he has worked
on something spent a lot of time on it
and is waiting for your like either
eventual approval or disapproval and
no longer can you as the father like be
totally objective and do the thing but
you are now yeah yeah uh being watched
uh in this like the dynamic of
father and child in in a piece of thing
and so it's
it's muddled and it's not
um
it's not any more pure because you are
now being that object of viewing now did
you also have the experience of like
maybe being a little bit nervous about
showing it to him because you know you
felt it was cool up until that point and
then you you do show it to him and
you're like holy crap that's me on there
and i don't know if he's gonna like it
or not
i
actually hadn't really thought about
that one i was interested in his
reaction
but i wasn't too worried that much about
that reaction yeah and partly because i
had already shown it to another a number
of people who enjoyed it and guess i
wasn't
too wrapped up in the the specific
approval of my father yeah but you could
have been i could have been absolutely
so i gotta ask before we go on
does this film still exist out there
somewhere like on the internet i do have
a copy of it but it's not on the
internet okay
i i took part in a um
it was it wasn't a student production it
was a bunch of us professors and it was
at fayetteville state university
when the um
the director of communications had
gotten his hands on some cameras and
like a studio and stuff like that they
were like expanding and he wanted to
create i don't exactly remember what the
movie was about all i remember is i had
a scene where i i walked in
and
shot
the
the chair of another department
and
um then we like you know took his body
and and
put it somewhere i'm very hazy on on all
the details
and so um they gave me like a fake gun
and they used some really horrible
special effects in the
editing to like you know try to make
blood you know and make like a something
like a gunshot
and so i went in and i don't remember
why i was supposed to be
you know
pressuring him but i didn't get what i
wanted and so i pulled a gun and shot
him and um i i walked in the way i
normally walk and i don't really pay
attention to how i walk you know but i
was being video recorded
and
later on my now wife then fiance
said as she was watching this this
youtube clip she's like wow you really
walk thuggish and i was like what do you
mean
and she said i mean you had it down
perfect for that scene and i was like
well i wasn't trying to walk thuggish i
was just walking the way i walk and then
i started then i started getting a
little bit self-conscious
after that about you know looking at
myself how do i walk
and it's because of you know old
injuries like you know one of my ankles
is a little bit shot and
stuff like that
i mean there's i think there's lots and
lots of examples of like revealing who
we are when we're actually being
recorded or looked at or however we want
to put it
yeah was it was it you being watched as
an individual or is it you being
like kind of unconsciously being method
and you're
uh
acting there
no i was i was actually just trying to
like get the scene done uh okay
it just so happened that the way my body
works uh made me appear to be
that way you know
so did you become self-conscious when
andy said this to you yeah i started
looking at how i walked and actually
this does illustrate your question does
illustrate something so whenever we have
let's call it a presentation something
that can be interpreted
by another person something that can be
looked at it's always
ambiguous in the sense that you know we
would like to we would like things to be
one way so i'm you know i get up in
front of my class and i'm teaching
and i'm going to be a professor now and
you know this is a serious business
although we'll joke around at
appropriate points you know
and usually that works for me in the
classroom but i've seen some people who
walk into the classroom and it is just
chaos the students don't respond to them
or respect them
and it's a very different situation and
you can see
them trying to
you know put something out there that
the other people are
in effect rejecting or replacing with
with something different right and aging
has also shown me the old like the older
you get i'm finding the less people pay
attention to you which is kind of nice
sometimes right you can easily slip by
nobody's
looking at you and trying to size you up
or anything
but we're always caught in this play of
like you know i want to be seen this way
other people want to see you a different
way
um
and we can't control how other people
view us
or what interpretations they they put on
to us
and so
maybe we should talk about
being objects
yeah yeah the view of others
so uh would you um
we've got this thing being seen by other
by another is an irreducible fact that
cannot be decided or distorted deduced
from the other as object or
by my being a subject i was hoping that
you would elaborate on those terms
yeah so
being seen by another is is
just what it is it's it's a
another person having me in their gaze
but but the way that sart
in being in nothingness is using the
gaze it's a
it's not just an experience
it's a structure of our existence and
it's always there whether somebody's
looking at us or not it's always
potentially
there
and
the the we can you know when we're
looking at other people like i'm looking
at you on a screen right now
you're you're existing as an object for
me with a bunch of properties but you're
also not just an object because if you
were you would be a mannequin or a robot
or or you could be a computer generated
image and if all i think you're just a
computer generated image
like an npc in a
you know video game or something like
that
unless i perceive that intentionality
that
agency in a certain sense coming from
you which which isn't there in any of
the stuff i'm looking at it's not there
in your eyeballs it's not there in your
shirt it's not there and any of that
sort of stuff it's a structure
of our
way of being in the world that we grasp
some things
as as having whatever you want to call
it a soul a spirit a mind an intention
and we can be wrong too like we can walk
into i i used to have this experience
when i was working security at lakeland
college second shift i was the second
shift commander and the worst thing was
having to go into the theater because
you'd have to patrol the whole area and
they had this room
way up on top and it was where they kept
like you know clothes and
i don't know
all the accoutrements that go with stuff
but they had mannequins in there and it
was dark and you'd walk in there and it
was so creepy
because
even though you would tell yourself okay
these are just mannequins
you know if you've seen enough horror
movies
or shows mannequins sometimes come to
life and it's hard to keep yourself from
not projecting that out there onto them
even though you know cognitively these
are just mannequins these are just wood
or plastic or whatever they are right so
so this is something
you know we look at the other as an
object and we also understand ourselves
as subjects but it this is all
reversible
so i look at you you're looking at me
there's like a song that goes like that
i don't remember what the song is but um
the the fact that i can see you as
another person means that i can be swept
up in your gaze
right
and objectified myself
and now
you are
aware
of
my own
subjectivity because you are aware that
i
see you as a potential object and in
order for that to be true i would have
to be a subject myself yeah and you know
the way that start describes it is is
quite interesting
he says that another person reorients
the world he describes it like
he's usually pretty um pessimistic about
this you know the other person is like a
whole that sucking being into that that
spot right um but there's something to
that like you're doing your own thing
think about the workplace right you're
doing your own thing on your computer
and you're lost in your work and then
suddenly somebody comes behind you and
they're talking over you at your
shoulder about what operation you should
do instead of the way that you're doing
things on the keyboard and suddenly it's
no longer just like your computer your
keyboard your
world that object even though you're the
one still in charge with your fingers on
the keyboard has been in a certain sense
contaminated by the other the other
person coming in and messing around
right and even even when they're gone
they're still kind of looking over your
shoulder right in your head
they've you cert part of your like
i don't know your equanimity in doing
the things that you want to do with your
own self and your own
uh i guess workspace or objects in this
example yeah
so
you know another thing that that sart
says that i think is really kind of uh
fascinating and is important is that the
look is not in the eyeballs
so
i can he actually i think goes too far
with this he says you know if i if i
look at your eyeballs and i appreciate
them as eyeballs i can't i can't
perceive the gays coming at me and i
think he's probably wrong about that um
but
it isn't just in the eyes
because you could be turned around
and i could be not facing you and still
think you're looking at me
or to use the example that he has about
the farmhouse during war that farmhouse
up on the hill it could be vacant but it
could also be where a sentry is posted
and they are watching me
and within a minute they're going to be
calling down artillery on on my position
or shooting at me with with a rifle or
who knows what else heading heading
around to capture me
and extend it to
like
any sense in which uh i am perceiving
you
as an object
and so i was hearing you
um if you know with the our expanded
um
sensorium you could call it yeah of of
technology
now we have a whole new plethora of of
abilities to sense people and we might
present that as visual data on a screen
but that is like from senses that are
beyond our natural ability but we're
still like
perceiving these things
um in a way that is not directly through
the eyeball
and
you know even like you you're
uh you know think of you know being in
the dark with you know uh your uh lover
partner and you you can't really see it
as like say it's pitch dark but you are
you're still perceiving this person
through touch and yeah you know what not
well and you could still actually worry
about what you look like in the dark
or what you feel like yeah yeah
you know
to talk about technological things you
know we can expand this and say
the look is not in the camera it it's
mediated through the camera like when
you're when your webcam goes on
and you see that whatever color light it
is like on mine it's a green light
because i have apple stuff it might be a
different color on others
mine's blue it's telling you somebody's
some somebody something's looking at you
right
and
you whether whether anybody's on the
other end or not um
it can be a little
disconcerting i mean that's why people
put up fake security cameras
right because this this uh
it doesn't even have to be a genuine
look
you can just make people think that
they're they're being watched
yeah are we
jumping the gun to foco here well do you
want to jump down to that talking about
this panopticon concept and we'll come
back to some of the other stuff
uh as as we we go on i mean this is
for for our society this is really
a key so yeah yeah sure let's jump so
we're talking about surveillance society
to a certain well not to a certain
extent this is exactly what we're
talking about
um and so like i'm most familiar with uh
michelle pucco's um working of his
panopticon um from discipline and punish
and
uh
so the the panopticon is described as a
prison in which there are
uh circular floors uh and an open
like uh
mezzanine
all the floors are in mezzanines and
they are overlooked by a central pillar
that has a
viewing port for the guards and the
guards can look out of the sport and
into any one of the cells at any one
time
but the slats are designed in such a way
that they can look out but the prisoners
cannot look in
and so not only are the prisoners could
be
uh viewed at any moment but uh even if
they are not they have the perception of
always being watched because they never
know when they are not being watched and
so the whole idea here is that we have a
system in which
the people are self-policing
because they don't know if they are
being watched or not yeah i think he he
also talks about this as like
uh religions often use the idea of a
all-seeing god as a you know a
panopticon to maintain certain
societal norms and uh making sure people
follow the rules
yeah foucault was less concerned about
that in particular the religious aspect
and much more about
what happens in our own society as we
adopt these um these sort of features
right and and what's interesting so in
in the original panopticon it's jeremy
bentham the great utilitarian
philosopher who comes up with the plan
and and actually suggests it as a prison
reform that he wants to see in england
he is very angry about the fact that
they rejected it and attributed it to
the aristocrats wanting to keep things
back in the dark ages and you know
basically keep keep things the way they
were and it was it was intended not to
be something just to like look at people
to screw with them or make them neurotic
which which it did unfortunately
um but to like you said to get them to
self-police so you get a criminal
to not only quit being criminal because
they don't want to get punished but to
start
policing themselves
right so this is this is quite an idea
and um there bentham also had something
else built into it that i think often
gets lost and it goes back to the old
question with plato's republic who will
guard the guardians right so bentham's
answer is that it will be public
officials who will be watching these
guards because you know if you know some
prison guards you know that they will
sometimes abuse power
and just mess with people to mess with
people so you have to have some watchers
of the watchers and then public opinion
so bentham imagined like back in his day
they didn't have tv or anything but you
would you would like have tours and and
people could come through and watch what
the guards are doing so the watchers are
being watched while they watch the
watches you could say
and um
the few places where this was tried
it it did not have the effects that
bentham thought it would in fact it made
people very paranoid
it made them compliant but it also
tended to deform the personality now
foucault
says
we don't actually have to have prisons
where things are set up this way
we can have like you said a disciplinary
society bentham by the way didn't just
think that this should apply to prisons
he thought it should apply to workshops
where people imagine like you know uh
you're you're working in the factory and
somebody's watching you all the time
which
is just horrible for me because i do
significantly worse
when people are at my job while someone
is watching me especially if it's like
someone that is watching with a critical
eye yeah like if i have a um a colleague
and we're working on something together
that's fine but if i have like a boss
that is looming
um
and watching and judging yeah and then
all of a sudden like i i
can't like you know turn a screwdriver
correct
it's it's a self-fulfill what they call
a self-fulfilling prophecy right you're
being watched just in case you screw up
and it makes you more likely to screw up
right um
so yeah so
workhouses
hospitals you know you don't want people
messing around with their bandages or
you know you don't want people doing
things they're not supposed to do off in
the dark corners
schools
bentham thought this could be okay for
for schools
and so
coming back to the disciplinary society
if we think about workers right what is
the what are the biggest complaints
about some of the
places where people um
can get jobs
and
have to you know endure a lot of
watching
you know you
you have to be monitored in terms of gps
or
how often you take a bathroom break or
how fast you're getting things done
and it really um
you know really makes for an unpleasant
work experience places like amazon for
example you know been in the news
because of that i would say that is part
of the disciplinary society the way
foucault is
talking about
um you know in in the workplace or in
schools you know there my kids
have so much data on them
you know when we were when we were young
i i can't speak for dan because dan is a
bit younger than me there was always
this threat of this is going to go into
your permanent record and it would be
something that would be typed or written
down and go into like a folder and you
could probably go and physically destroy
it if you got your hands on it and then
computers came in and maybe your
permanent record would be in the
computer um
now there's like tons and tons and tons
of data about these these kids and
what's going on with them in school in
some sense
and and not just like schools because we
now live in an age where oh yeah we all
have like cameras uh in our pockets and
we have social media and the ability to
post this stuff
and i don't know about you
but i did some stupid things when i was
a teenager
that i am very much happy that i don't
have any uh you know
tangible record of it because we are all
dumb when we were teenagers you know i
first got onto social media when i was
around 40
and it's probably a good thing that i
waited that long in my life
and also like
on a mild tangent i i think there's
um like i'm happy that i didn't have it
but i don't also
think that
people are going to stop caring
especially as the people that grew up
with that as part of their lives yeah
become the adults and so i think the the
only place where it's a particular issue
is the the people that
that grew up without it having
places of positions of power and judging
those who did have it
um because now they can say like you
know i don't have any of this but you do
and so i can kind of like
talk you know actually uh having any of
this own
uh available to
you know put down my own self yeah i
mean i kind of think that some of the
people who didn't grow up with
the internet and social media
not all of them i mean i'm i'm in that
group myself but many are
really terrible at
understanding and using it
and i also think that the younger
generations are also
on the large part pretty terrible in
using it and understanding it as well
just in different ways you know um i
mean
you think about the stuff that we do
post and the fact that it's out there
now forever
you know and anybody can look at it
anybody can bring it under their their
gaze
you know
for example there there were some i
think it was at marquette recently there
was a
uh
a
young woman who
was accepted and then was told not to
not to come by the administration
because of her racist remarks in social
media
you know things like that can can get
out there and haunt you
and you know some people may say well
you know good that's that's the way it
should work
but there's all sorts of much more
innocuous stuff that we do
that and going back to to sartre
anything that we do can be interpreted
in ways that we
wouldn't want it interpreted by somebody
else who's brought us within their gaze
right they can turn us into an object
that
we're not happy with
right
uh and so
i want to go a little bit back to
like the surveillance society in that
yeah yeah it used to be that like you
want to take a look at it right yeah
that london was kind of like the the
poster child because they put up such a
large
amount of ctvs
yeah but they were they're all like kind
of poster like uh man by humans
so there's like people like you know big
old banks of cameras you're just
watching that or you can like play back
if you had like someone say like there
was a crime at this one time in place
yeah but that's kind of nothing compared
to the advent of our at least uh ais
that are allowed to like uh
uh create um
object detection they're literally
objectifying people
um
through
programmatic algorithms and then also
like i know i guess
to take china as an example uh applying
like social scores to them so it's not
just like
your your peers or your your close
neighbors or families that are are
watching and objectifying you about your
of the entire society
yeah we should we should for our
listeners who don't know what we're
talking about there it's called the
social credit system
right and it's been around for a while
and it was optional at first but
optional in the sense like everybody
should volunteer and if you don't you're
going to stick out like a sore thumb
what do you have to lose if you don't do
it and
the
you know it was tied in so imagine if
your facebook account and twitter and
whatever other social media instagram
were also connected with your school
records connected with your work hr
records
um records banking yeah your travel
stuff
how well you are a good neighbor and or
a partner to your any relationships
maybe even like when it comes to school
records how your kids are doing too yeah
right and so this is all placed into one
big system which determines things like
are you
okay to travel from province to province
or are you you know one of those people
they should keep an eye on
um we have you know quite a few networks
but fortunately our networks are not
well integrated like this
you know this is something like out of a
sci-fi movie but but it's it's
building its way into
active existence and that may be an
issue for us here as well
yeah um
you know we're always building systems
that are like a little bit more and more
integrated and
um you know there are some uh states and
cities that have uh proactively said
like we're not going to do any like
facial recognition
uh but there's so much
like
uh want from potential policing or
whatnot to actually have these systems
in place that i feel like eventually
unless there's some really hard pushback
these systems are going to be
implemented
you know and i was let me ask you
because you're you're you know more of a
tech guy than i am in
many different ways
um so the big tech companies you know we
think about the the big five google
facebook
amazon
microsoft and apple
all of them have these kind of hegemonic
desires to you know control everything
they often frame it in very nice ways
like oh we just want to be involved in
every area of your life you know and
make your life wonderful but you know
when you watch them fighting against
each other it's clear that they're
they're trying to dominate space and
some you know just like is with like the
food and beverage industry so many of
the other things that we're used to
using
belong to these companies so microsoft
owns skype and owns linkedin and owns a
whole bunch of other things as well um
you know google a whole variety of
things right from from uh
youtube to
search engine to you you know google
suite that we use in all the educational
uh institutions that i work um and we
could go on and on and on right amazon
in this case has has the uh um the
doorbell thing is that is that link
ring ring yeah
they
serve like you know two-thirds of the
internet with aws and yeah they own uh
whole foods and
you know there's so many places touch
places where they can gather more
information to create a better profile
of you and that's exactly what they've
been doing right they have been we are
objects for these big tech companies
and
you know i i kind of so here i'm going
to throw this out and i want to see you
you run with it you brought up like
police wanting to have surveillance
powers
it seems like where the real
um
catalyst for that would come would be
these big tech companies that have these
things in place and then could like turn
them over to policing so we might not
end up with one vast single system of
social credit but maybe we end up with
something that's like a piecemeal
one by my google street or my amazon
score yeah i mean does that seem
what do you think is that something
a dystopian future that we have to look
out for
uh i think it is especially
because it seems like in the last
uh decade or so the biggest uh revenue
generator is to create the closest
models for
on each individual user in order to uh
serve them
you know targeted ads
yeah and that that is like the the major
uh
profit generator for the vast majority
of these companies that are data first
which like all these big five are
uh to
a greater or lesser extent uh kind of
data first uh organizations
and
uh yeah if at some point in time if you
know
the government wants to start building
these things
they already have it like ready served
and you know those it's
we're entering into these or are these
um
arrangements with these companies
through this like you know contract law
um which doesn't you know apply to like
the fourth amendment and once it's you
know out there and someone has it they
can you know potentially give it over to
the government because it wasn't the
government that was
searching and seizing that but uh it was
given to someone else third party uh
through your own free will you know
quotation marks yeah
that's interesting so we inhabit a very
different
environment
you could say one that's that's mediated
through
vast server banks and algorithms and
things like that way beyond what sart
was was worried about or even even maybe
michel foucault you know
he died back in the early 80s
he didn't he could see some of the the
writing on the wall but
um
certainly not not anything like where we
are now
right let's we we kind of live in a
um
you know
some of the sci-fi writers like greatest
worries but we're like
it's fun i get my packages in two days
and uh i've got you know all the things
on the internet all the world's
knowledge and all the worlds you know
comedy and stupidity all at my
fingertips it's really fun
yeah that's true well there there's a
devil's bargain there right yeah well
let's talk about before we run out of uh
time and maybe we come back to start
later if we have the time but let's talk
about the male gaze because i know that
was something that was motivating you
to to uh talk about this in the first
place
um i mean this isn't a radically new
concept i think simone de beauvoir is
talking about something like this in
the second sex
and others were before
but the the term the male gaze is kind
of new or relatively new i mean older
than you um just a little bit you know
younger than me so
uh yeah so like at least within
a film theory um it's this idea of
you know um
most film at least in the like
the 70s when this idea was
being proposed that you know we have
three major gazes of that the
perspective of the man behind the camera
the perspective of the male characters
in the film story and the perspective of
the male
spectator gazing at the movie and images
as the major audiences for
the
type of images that are being shown and
it's uh like what what is pleasing to
that male eye
um and mostly it is you know reducing a
a female to you know an object of desire
specifically uh sexual
yeah and and you know this is again
something that has been going on for a
very long time that notion sex sells and
advertising
was a way of expressing this i would say
and you know there's a book called the
hidden persuaders written back in the
50s that goes into this in in great
depth you know
using psychoanalysis to to explain it
um
i i kind of think as you were talking
about that
you see this a lot in the 70s you see
this a lot in the 80s and in the movies
there and i think i don't think it's
it's changed all that much
in movies that's still
pretty
male gaze centered um there's some
notable exceptions and they're sometimes
like turning the tide like you know
think about the movie the full monty
where women get to look at naked guys
um or you know female gays yeah yeah
people talk about that but sometimes
some people say well the female gaze is
basically just like changing the male
gaze around it's still the same
structure somebody's looking at somebody
else and objectifying them
um
yeah just to continue with that like
objectify someone as a object of desire
yeah ownership um of something to be won
as a competition for prestige or for
dominance
yeah
so
i mean what do you what do you make of
this
is this connected with
sart's uh
view of the gaze or is this something
additional does this tie in at all with
the the worries that we were expressing
about panopticonism
and surveillance um
i kind of see these as interconnected
myself
i would agree especially because like
not only does it like reinforce
um
kind of like certain notions of what a a
woman should be
but also for the
the woman it creates the
uh object or the idea of like well what
what should i be if i if this is the
idea of the ideal
um do i need to
uh modify myself in order to placate
these things
or hide parts of myself or yeah
right
which is you know i guess
male centered instead of like you know
my own
uh subject centered yeah
so what do we mean by subject centered
in that that case that that's a really
important
idea
uh and it connects back to
existentialism this notion that you
aren't just an object you aren't just
what people
see you as or classify you
as um you're also subject
yeah what is it so what is being a
subject what does that mean
um
i i would defer to the professor at the
moment
okay i was looking to elicit some some
springboard i mean part of it is is i
guess you could say
part of it is the
capacity to choose for yourself how you
want to be looked at
right um
i mean you you can't define yourself
totally and and i think the
existentialists are right about this
they you can't like say
well i'm you know a 51 year old
uh kind of out of shape guy
everyone should look at me as if i'm a
21 year old greek god statue you know
that that's that's ridiculous or
um i want everyone to see me as a
um
five foot one
um frenchman with a beret even though
i'm not wearing a berry okay there's
some things that are ridiculous that way
but i do think that
there is a lot of um
putting people into categories and
defining them and
this is this this does work along power
differentials so that means that it does
work along matters of class
or
authority or in this case gender
and so there i mean today we still have
a lot of schools where take for example
dress codes you know this is a prime
example of worries about the gays
um in in you know middle schools and
high schools my own
uh oldest daughter used to complain
about this a lot
there's this emphasis on girls not
wearing revealing clothing because that
draws the male gaze and can distract
them can provoke reactions and there's
very little holding of the the male
students accountable for the fact that
they can they can direct where they want
their eyeballs to go you know
and
um a lot of
things that are okay for
male students to get away wearing aren't
aren't considered okay for female
students i would say that that's an
expression
of this and interestingly it's not just
men who are imposing this it's also
uh you know women principals and women
teachers and what you know mothers and
and people like that who are enforcing
these these notions of modesty that mary
wollstonecraft kind of blew up back in
the you know 17 1790s
yeah
um
so i i mean i think that's part of it
being able to have some
stake in how you're going to be looked
at
um
[Music]
but i mean there's more part of that is
like the
the roles that you are presented with as
you know at least right
looking at what is acceptable in society
and the roles that you are given as a
position within that society and kind of
like uh this kind of brings up the
bechtel test which is the idea of like
in this old idea like there's like
you're either a wife or like a
object desire um
uh or you're or a secretary right yeah
and
um and most
of these films and tv don't have any
women that actually just talk to each
other about things that weren't like
about a man and so the neck tail test is
three parts of it you have to have at
least two p women named women
specifically um
in the the piece who talk to each other
about something besides a man um and
that is like a minimum to bringing
someone out of uh this you know very
narrow kind of myopic view of what women
can be in this media yeah and so that
affects film and television i i guess we
could say it it also affects maybe radio
um depending on what the show is
oriented towards
um i also kind of think that in our so
you know we brought up this this digital
age that we're in with mobile technology
and you know an internet that is spread
over the entire world and and exists you
know everywhere and nowhere
um
so you know images that people have of
gender relations
you know and particular particularly
sexuality
we get quite distorted views through
um you know things like say say you know
mainstream pornography right but but
also equally through advertising
and it's um you know it's still pretty
widespread um that's that's not
radically changing and it leads to a lot
of miserable people this this kind of
comes back to jean-paul sartre's
view of the gays you know we could view
it as like a call to responsibility
you know he's got that famous thing if
you're looking through the the keyhole
and and you know you're like
he says out of vice um
what vice jealousy or or curiosity right
so you're you're looking at somebody
doing something that you know
you're you're not supposed to be
watching and then suddenly you hear
somebody behind you and he says you know
it could maybe not it's not it's not
something it's just a floor creaking but
you you you're you know you're tense
suddenly right
and you're the object of someone else's
exactly
exactly and so
there's there's a lot of this um
you know looking at other people but
also then measuring ourselves in
relation to that
and so you know unrealistic ideas about
um what we should look like in terms of
our our nether parts you know uh have
been an issue
but also interestingly enough um i mean
that people have been reporting this
the
the rate of
young men having body dysmorphia and
like going to the gym
and working out a lot and still feeling
like they're not big enough they're you
know they're not defined enough
i'd say that that's come about because
of the internet age as well and
something else that we were talking
about before we started the show
there has been a recent boom in plastic
surgery since the pandemic
why is that while people are
seeing themselves and they're seeing
themselves as they would be seeing
themselves through the eyes of another
through
zoom skype
google meet
i don't know what else other people use
for video conferencing dan you would
know more than i would uh what's that
there's shitsy there's microsoft teams
there's a number of others yeah there
you go i think i blanked out on
microsoft teams because i dislike using
it so much
but but people have been seeing
themselves in these meetings and then
they think
i should get some plastic surgery i
don't look as good as i should now are
they coming to that idea just by
themselves or are they doing that
because they're looking at themselves
through the eyes
of others and finding themselves not to
be good enough
could be both could be
uh
people actually saying something or like
this whole just
always seeing
and being seen yeah
in a way that we would not in a normal
interaction i mean we don't really know
all we do know is that the industry
plastic surgery is worried that the boom
is going to end as people move move back
into like offices
so that's an interesting thing to
to you know cap it all off i'd say or
we've just created a whole new
generation of narcissists
i hope not because
narcissists are high maintenance
right and who's got the energy for that
not me
got too much going on
yeah me me too i mean i ca i don't want
a a classroom full of narcissists myself
now
well should we wrap it up what do you
think yeah
so uh today
we'd leave you with the words of
jean-paul
man is always separated from what he is
by all the breath of being which he is
not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you